Add the genetic testing done.
How can I find out if I was tested for the following genes,
the MTHFR, the MCY, the CMT, the MTR, the MTR?
I don't know how to read the book, I was given.
Well, that's why we have the course.
So I do understand that reading your genes
can be extremely complicated.
So I tried to make as many videos as possible
and we put them on the course.
And remember, you have full access of the course as a member.
So go on the major genes course
and you can look at those videos
so you can see what is going on and what those genes mean.
Yes, if you did your genetic profile with us,
all these genes were tested.
And it's hard to know, well, where are they?
What category are they in?
I don't even know what they are.
Because in your full complete genetic profile,
they're categorized, not alphabetically.
They're categorized based upon function.
So you could just read down the full genetic profile
if you want.
It's very large.
When this person had theirs done, it was probably 200 in some pages.
It's almost 350 pages long.
That gets complicated.
That's why I also give you an abbreviated genetic profile
called what do I call it?
I think I call it genetic summary.
So the genetic summary is about 18 pages long.
And I only highlight the genes that you have an issue with.
So go to your genetic summary and look at that.
And then that's still 18 pages long.
So I break it down and give you a genetic action step sheet.
That's only about two to three pages long.
So really to address those genes that you need to take action.
I will say right off the top, the MTHFR gene
with somebody who has cancer.
Even if you have double allele defects on both genes in that family,
there's two genes in the MTHFR gene family.
Even if you had a double allele defect on both those genes,
I still wouldn't prescribe a person to take methylfolate
if you have cancer, really a person that has cancer
that should be taking methylfolate
or methylclobalamine should be somebody
that has an elevated hormone cysteine levels.
So if you have normal homocysteine levels,
now that's homocysteine is not a gene,
it's in your complete metabolic panel.
So that if your homocysteine levels are within normal range,
and you have a history of cancer,
regardless of whether you have defects on your MTHFR gene
or not, you should not be taking methylated folate.
And nobody should be taking synthetic folate period.
Here, what's good?
Your gene has to do with formal production
and your transporter production.
That is in your biopterant pathway.
Your MTHFR and your MTHFR gene
is how you create vitamin B12
and utilize vitamin B12.
If you have defects in that pathway,
I typically recommend it for you to be on B12,
but if you have a diagnosis of cancer,
I typically recommend hydroxyl,
comolamine or the adenosyl comolamine,
not the methyl comolamine.
So all that information is in those three
on that whole genetic profile gives you a list
of all your gene defects.
The genetic action steps is the most summarized one
that I gave you.
And of course, if you're still confused
and you just want to talk about it,
we'll just go ahead and self-schedule an appointment with me
and we could go over there.
So no problem, I'm more than happy to clarify
any questions that anybody has.
I'll do the best that I possibly can
to schedule a time to go over there.
But also, when you get to this self-scheduling,
your follow-up calls,
you need to fill out this form right here.
But when you self-schedule,
you do click on that,
you'll have the option to self-schedule a Zoom call
or just to schedule a phone call.
Why would I want to do a Zoom call?
If you're going over labs,
if you want me to go over your labs
or go over your genetics,
then you want to make it a Zoom call
because then I can share my screen
and I can easily point to see this.
This is what this means
and I can pull up documents
and share different things
and make it a better educational call.
If it's just to talk about your plan
or something like that,
then you could just make it a phone call.
Okay, question pertaining to this,
I have high almost 16
and have been taking methyl B12 for almost three months.
It's slowly coming down.
What exactly is the risk of taking methyl B12
if you have cancer?
So methyl groups do several things in your body.
One of the things methyl groups do
is that they silence genes
and we don't want access methyl groups
with somebody that has cancer
because you could turn off two groups of preser genes.
There are other risks of taking excess methyl groups
and by excess methyl groups,
that would be somebody who's taking
a fairly medium to high dose methyl folate
and taking methyl cobalamine
because their practitioner
heard about the MTHFRG,
usually that's the case
or they read something on Instagram or Facebook
about the MTHFRG is the cause of all disease
which is total nonsense.
There's a lot of nonsense out there
about the MTHFRG,
more nonsense than any genetic gene in a genetic test
because there's just so many practitioners
who I don't know how to say it nicely,
but don't understand the whole big picture of genes
and they readily prescribe methyl folate
and a methyl cobalamine with somebody
thinking that, oh, you have MTHFRG, D-Fect,
well, you just need to get on some methyl groups
and then they put people at fairly high dose methyl groups
of eight times one to five grams of methyl folate.
The issue with that is that it's even worse
than just the cancer piece.
It's even if you don't have cancer,
if you have defects in the biopterin pathway,
then it pushes that pathway really hard
so it really can change your brain neurochemistry
and it can cause excess rage and excess OCD issues,
especially if you also have those biopterin pathway,
defects on your dopamine pathway,
your serotonin pathway, your gad pathway,
making glutamates and it can cause a lot of emotional instability.
So, I can't tell you how many people that I've spoken to,
especially whenever a year ago,
when I was doing a lot of genetic consultations,
the people that were put on methyl support
because the doctor only knew to read the intensive car gene
and these people were having serious relationship problems
and rage issues and all sorts of problems
and it gets very serious.
So, you don't want to do that.
Now, when do you go on methyl groups?
I really think you only go on methyl groups
if you have issues with homocysteine levels
and have no history of cancer
or issues with homocysteine levels and cancer
or you have, if you looked at the rest of the genes,
so you gotta take a 30,000 foot view of genetics
to really look at all of them together
and see how everything works together
because for metamox damping, everything does work together.
This is why too much of a good thing can be a bad thing
with supplements you could be pushing pathways
if you don't want to push.
Now, certainly somebody who has MTRR and MTR defects,
you do want to support vitamin B12.
The vitamin B12 deficiency goes way beyond just a genetic issue.
A person can have no defects on these pathways
and still could have serious B12 absorption problems
but what's the number one cause of that?
Well, a decreased hydrochloric acid production in the stomach,
if you're not making hydrochloric acid in the stomach,
you're not gonna be making the intrinsic factor
because the intrinsic factor production and utilization
is dependent upon HCl production
and intrinsic factor is how you absorb B12 from your food.
So if you're eating foods with B12,
in an orbit of your taking a B12 supplementation
and you have a decrease in HCl, that's why it's so important
to be supported hydrochloric acid
in your stomach and be taking hydrochloric acid
with your meals to at least your larger meals
to support that so that you have adequate absorption
of B12s because a lot of people are walking around
with fatigue, aka from academia and it's actually B12 anemia.
They have normal red blood cells, normal RBWs,
and everything and it's really a B12 anemia
because of HCl and it's relationship with intrinsic factor
and it's relationship with the ability, so over 12.
So you could get on the genetic course
and learn more about that as well
and I have some videos regarding that as well.